in today's morning rounds to Wisconsin
judges who now share a lifelong bond
judge Derrick Mosley needed a
life-saving kidney transplant when
fellow judge Joanne Irish stepped
forward Mosley returned to the bench
yesterday for the first time since the
surgery
Sarika Duncan is inside his Milwaukee
courtroom with her inspiring friendship
tarika good morning good morning in this
courthouse our two judges with
completely different backgrounds one
from the south side of Chicago the other
from the suburbs of Milwaukee well they
have formed an incredible friendship
that started without any judgment there
were plenty of hugs here to greet 46
year old judge Derrick Mosley let's do
some business as he retook the bench all
rise he had one person to thank 58 year
old judge Joanne Irene I have a part of
my best friend in me you know and that I
feel that could actually touch you know
inside of me that keeps me alive in 2014
it became clear Mosley's kidneys were
failing doctors diagnosed him with in
stage renal disease I was on daily
dialysis I did it for ten hours a day
every day of the week what did the
doctors tell you in terms of the
likelihood of you getting a kidney soon
yeah well soon soon was five to six
years since 1991 the number of people
waiting for organs has risen 426 percent
while the number of donors is only up
117 percent the need is especially great
among African Americans who make up 13%
of the population but account for more
than a third of all patients waiting for
kidneys I ring didn't want her friend to
wait so she stepped up to see if she was
a match I would like to think that
people would do whatever they can for
their friends and I don't feel like I'm
a hero
this is who I am and this is how I was
brought up turns out I ring who is half
mosely size had kidneys that were a
perfect fit
a reminder that it's not about what's on
the outside but on the inside I had
joked too long to the doctors you know
don't be fooled by my size I have big
feet big bones I'm pretty sure I have
big organs too and that was just kind of
a joke we all had and it was a huge
doctors transplanted that huge kidney
last month it's already allowing Mosley
to spend more time with his two
daughters and wife while deepening his
friendship with his fellow judge I'd go
one step further it sounds like your
family we're family yeah that's and I
think that's what I want people know we
all get caught up in the fact that you
know some people don't associate with
other people because of their race or
what have you but you know when it comes
down to it inside we're all the same you
know one heart two lungs two kidneys the
more you interact with other people are
different from you the more you learn
the more you grow as a person
that's the diversity that makes us great
and I just think people need to embrace
that more judge Mosley says that he
expects judge Irene to keep a close eye
on his diet while here at work because
he said she wants to make sure that he
keeps her kidney well now his kidney
healthy Josh seems fair to Rika Duncan
thank you for that and you know I beg to
differ
she is a hero Oh beautiful beautiful and
and I got it to you this guy's there is
no other city that deserves the store
like this more than Milwaukee we just
actually did a story in it a couple of
weeks ago a study out shows that it is
still America's most segregated City no
Waukee and so when you see a store like
this there's hope
Long's while giving people one create a
tough yeah